what's that believe nation today I want
to make a special congratulations video
to a friend of mine Antonio Centeno who
recently crossed 1 million subscribers
on youtube so Antonio has a channel
called real men real style giving advice
to men on how to dress better and have
more style have more confidence in their
day-to-day life and he recently crossed
a million subscribers and so I reached
out to some of his most loyal fans and
asked if they would like to contribute
to a special tribute video
congratulating him here are some of the
responses you are so beautiful Antonio
what's happening great to see you and
welcome to the club it's been a while
it's been a long time coming but you
finally did it 1 million subscribers
post some you're already almost like
ready to pass me and it couldn't have
happened to a better dude you're
incredible your content is fantastic
you've helped a ton of people along the
way but most importantly you've been an
amazing friend and supporter of mine so
thank you congratulations enjoy the ride
sir and I'll see you at two million
Antonio congrats on hitting 1 million
subscribers you are a huge inspiration
to me and I almost look at you as a big
brother and an inspiration that really
drives me to improve myself and to
improve the projects that I'm working on
congrats on your success and here's to
another million sure hey Antonia Sam he
I don't want to thank you for making
such stylish videos for guys like me you
might need to make a couple more but
seriously congratulations mate on
reaching a million subscribers hell of
an achievement you deserve it so well
done good work what's up Antonio this is
jeremy what's up guys just wanted to say
as well
happy birthday congratulations to the 1
million subscriber and thank you for
always supporting me not only via email
via skype but also through two videos
actually already I mean I don't take
that for granted you definitely pushed
me over some of your subscribers thank
you very much for that totally
appreciated and definitely would love to
meet you in person so keep going for the
next 1 million to get to the two million
saying hello from Hawaii peace hey
Antonio is Jordy here from cine calm and
thank you so much for putting out these
great tips and information on YouTube
you've been teaching me so many new
things and one of them is that you can
define success with the correct mindset
and how you deliver a certain message
and I was able to implement your IDs and
tips into my very small channel but it's
now a sustainable business and it was
even able to hire my very first employee
so thank you so much for that and of
course congratulations on hitting 1
million subscribers hey guys is how you
for seeing me today so I want to wish
and tell me you and his team over a real
man real set of huge congratulations to
rigga for hating past 1 million
subscribers I mean this is just crazy
but you know what you guys work so hard
at it conflict helping out great content
ranging from topics such as five tips to
save on name brand 220 things i
mentioned never wear now i am so excited
to see what you guys in putting up mini
a future and congratulations tenuta goal
cheers and see you later guys bye
Antonia big congratulations on reaching
the one William subscribe with mine
shown this is indeed a very big feed for
the entire men's lifestyle communities
even like you and add another
undoubtedly three of the biggest
inspiration see of the biggest mentors
out there and I and my small lens
essentials community cannot thank you
enough cannot compassionate enough so we
wish you lots more success may or 2017
be more epic may inspire and Lily
hey what's going on Antonio Robert
walked me here from koi na TV just
wanted to send you big congratulations
on reaching 1 million subscribers on
your real men real style youtube channel
every time I watch one of your videos I
feel 1% closer to being the handsome
devil that I should be once again
congratulations Antonio congratulations
on the 1 million subscribers that is
awesome I just want to say I really
appreciate everything that you've done
for me in the YouTube community as a
whole I remember like years ago when
you're like one of the first people
using YouTube to really grow a business
and and I remember you reaching out to
me sending me lots of free information
just to help me out like Tim this is
what you should be doing and and now
today I'm doing it so thank you so much
for your advice years ago you support
for me and even now what you're doing to
connect me with other people and I just
know you you / you just pour some what's
in the YouTube community and into the
people here on the space and to me as
well so thank you so much graduations
are 1 million subscribers and I'm really
looking forward to seeing you hit two
million really food hey I Sonya congrats
on your 1 million subscribers really
proud of you and you honestly deserve it
it just goes to show that with hard work
and dedication almost anything is
possible so you're really an inspiration
for us and honestly we couldn't be
happier for you hey Antonio
congratulations on your 1,000,000 like
my brother said hard work really does
pay off and you're an inspiration to
everybody and showing how much hard work
really pays off we wish you the best
success and now let's go for those two
million Antonio my name is Ramon and I
am an educator administrator and I also
moonlight as an artist and youtuber I
just want to wish you a congratulations
on 1 million subscribers that is a huge
accomplishment one that is a YouTube
where I wish to get to one day but most
importantly I want to thank you for your
insight and your knowledge because it
has definitely helped me in my career
and definitely thank you for helping me
become the best-dressed person at my
office here's to a million more
subscribers congratulations once again
and I know that you're going to probably
hate me for this but I am wearing some
baggy jeans with flip-flops and [ __ ]
right now but that's okay because today
I am working from home and I will
definitely put your knowledge
good news if I do step out of the door
so don't worry about that
congratulations i'm told you a million
sub 1 million subs that's a lot of subs
many great job for getting 2 million
subs i know a lot of people run the
world appreciate your constant you've
helped many people clothes the better
you look sharp we get a job and you've
probably helped a lot of single guys get
some play as well that serve them on a
friday night or saturday night but
you're a class act man really enjoyed
collaborating with these there's a lot
of people on youtube I your pure class
congrats once again out 1 million subs
congratulations on 1 million subscribers
I'm so happy for you i was watching your
channel before we even met and then we
didn't meet and it was awesome so
continue doing what you're doing
continue making your videos and and just
being a really cool dude and also uh
please tell me if I'm wearing that stars
correctly i'm i am all of a sudden very
self-conscious about it can tell you how
you're doing my name is field except
from Mexico City I just want to
congratulate you on your 1 million
subscriber milestone on YouTube it's an
incredible achievement usually deserve
it I also want to thank you for all your
amazing videos you have really helped me
keep up the good work sir so there you
have it Antonio as you see you've made a
big impact on the lives of a lot of
people I want to throw my hat in the
ring as well and a few lakhs
congratulations hitting 1 million
subscribers is an amazing mark I know
that's not just your end goal you want
to continue to add value and help people
and we've just been an amazing source of
inspiration thank you for your
friendship thank you for your offer to
open up doors and make connections to me
and bite me to events and the advice
you've given me on my youtube channel as
well I really really appreciate it man
so here's to the next million or maybe
hitting 10 million I'm super pumped and
excited for you and again big up big
congratulations and I'll see you soon
and PS guys if you haven't heard of
Antonio a real men real style yet go
check out the channel I think it going
to enjoy I've licked it up in the
description below
you